لا أعرف كيف أجيب أنني لا
أعرف كيف أجيب أنني أعتقد أن كل ما
أعنيه هو الزحام بالنسبة لي أمر جيد
وشيء سيء يعني أنك تحاول فعل
أي شيء عليك القيام به للعيش في
الحب  الحياة وأحيانًا يعني ذلك
إنشاء الأشياء أو تغيير الأشياء ، لكنني
كنت محظوظًا جدًا بالحصول على هذا الممثلين
وأنشأت كل الشخصيات لكل
منهم وقد جلبوا كل
شجاعتهم وخلقوا شخصيات لم يسبق لهم فعلها من
قبل كريستيان بيل آمي آدامز جينيفر
لورانس  عاد برادلي كوبر
وجيريمي رينر روبرت دي نيرو ، لذلك
أشعر بالسعادة لأنهم جاءوا وفعلوا
ذلك من أجلي ، وهذا امتياز كبير لي ، حيث
تظاهرت أنه استخدمه
كرجل ثري للقبض على الأشخاص الذين يريدون
الاستفادة من الأغنياء  الرجل وفي
الحياة الواقعية ، لم يكن حتى ميغيل بينا ، لقد
كان رجلًا أبيض وضع المكياج ،
لذا فالقصص الحقيقية أغرب من
الحقيقة التي أعنيها ، لكن بالنسبة لي هذا
هو المسرح ، فأنت تفهم ما أنا عليه
قول